welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Deborah Davis a professor of
sociology at Yale University professor
Davis's primary teaching and research
interests are historical and comparative
sociology inequality and stratification
and contemporary Chinese society she is
a member of the National Committee on
us-china relations and has just
completed a six-year term
chairing the social science and
humanities panel of the Hong Kong
government Research Committee this past
July professor Davis organized a
workshop at Hong Kong University as part
of a larger project on Chinese marriage
and sexuality today we talk with her
about the changing trends of marriage
and divorce in China
welcome professor Davis thank you very
much for having me let's begin with an
overview of your larger project tell us
about it the project actually began with
a study about privatization of real
estate you know that in the socialist
era in China which goes roughly from
1950 to 1980 in the cities if you own
your house you could keep your house but
gradually virtually all new housing was
publicly owned and a private housing was
reclaimed so the experience was of
people dependent on the state to arrange
their families and it had a huge impact
on many aspects of their lives
so I was writing a book about the
privatization of urban housing and in
the next-to-last chapter that I was
about to finish in this book I wanted to
look at what happens at divorce that is
I knew the rules of the game I knew the
law but I wanted to understand how did
people understand what was fair how did
they want to split this this home and
under these new conditions of market
socialism
as a result of doing the focus groups
and the follow up on divorce I realized
that really what was the big story or
make an original book would be a book
what I'm calling post-socialist marriage
so it's the way in which housing has
come to the heart of understanding why
people marry when people marry and the
quality of their marriage so I backed
into it and how do how does the paper he
present it in Hong Kong fit into this
larger project um what I did in Hong I
should step back last year when I was
working in Hong Kong
it became fascinating to me in the ways
in which marriage and sexual practices
in Hong Kong were looking more and more
on look what I was seeing on the other
side of the border and then when I
looked at other materials I realized
there was convergence between the Taiwan
Hong Kong and PRC experience so I put
together a group of people to
investigate what I call sexuality in
marriage and cosmopolitan China and the
paper I wrote in July is just one piece
of that comparison across the three
countries and my focus is particularly
on the legal aspect that is how the
States role visa vie marriage how
they've written the marriage law how
they've policed divorce in particular
reflects larger patterns of state
control over people's private lives and
what are some of the fundamental changes
in marriage that you're seeing in this
time period that you're researching oh
the time period is a little flexible
that is the paper really talks about the
last 10 years but the larger one goes
back 30 years in other words it goes
back to 1980 approximately when we think
of China's market reforms beginning it
also was the year in which they passed a
new marriage law and the marriage law
was sometimes seen by some people as a
divorce law because it made it much
easier for people to if couples agreed
to then simply file for divorce they
really didn't have to go through a court
procedure if both agreed and there was
no conflict
so it's over this 30 year period that I
that I'm really looking at there are
five things that are really remarkable
about 1980 to the present and first
comes from the affluence we all know
that that china has moved from being a
low income actually very impoverished
society to being lower middle income and
now more billionaires in China than any
place else in the world so you also have
enormous wealth one of the first things
that people did with their new wealth
whether they were very wealthy or
middling wealthy was to purchase homes
and therefore one of the key things
that's changed is that marriage now in
many cases depends on owning a home and
purchasing a home and the centrality of
that home ownership now occupies a
centrality in the spouse relationship
that was absent totally absent when it
was a public health of public housing
regime as it wasn't or socialism so the
first change is this housing piece and
their affluence piece the second is the
one-child policy which also has passed
in the same period 1980 is when it
starts to take effect and as soon as you
the state mandates one child per couple
you have radically changed the character
of marriage if marriage was about
becoming parents of usually two or more
children the sexual relationship with
spouses is different and also the
balance of power you could almost say in
the household is different so we're now
looking in urban China which is the
majority of people now in families in
which there are two adults and one child
and credly that creates a different
dynamic in a marriage or in which
children outnumber parents that's the
second thing the third is this vast
migration that we all know about 250
million Chinese have left their home
towns and moved elsewhere and this also
has changed marriage in a fundamental
way in that people find their partners
usually without very much supervision
from their parents direct supervision if
they're on the move and then it also
means that if there's a bad
ship a bad marriage people are much
freer to leave and start again so it's a
another huge change because in the
socialist era people were really nailed
to place and that was you were stuck
with the neighbors you had as well as
the spouse you had and now China is in a
very different place the fourth thing is
a Cultural Revolution not like the one
that Mao initiated in the 60s but one
that was commercially driven and also
driven by this reintegration of the
Chinese diaspora Hong Kong Southeast
Asia
Taiwan even in the United States so that
people returning to visit family or
people moving back and forth between
different Chinese communities brought
different sexual mores you could in an
earlier period the idea of of premarital
sex extramarital sexual relations was
often branded bourgeois and Western and
this is hardly the case ever Westerners
don't have a monopoly on these behaviors
and this has led to a liberalisation of
of people's sexual relationships which
is radically different than the
socialist era in which the government
really had quite a puritanical policing
of people's private lives and then the
last which is the other part of my paper
and what we're talking about is the
divorce revolution divorce rates now in
Taiwan Hong Kong and China are just
about the same as the United States and
it has ratcheted up very very quickly so
it's it's startling phenomena and that's
tied to liberalisation of the law but
also a totally different attitude by the
court officials who will now don't stand
in the way of divorce as they did before
so how has it changed that divorce is
easy there's a great deal of sexual
experimentation on sexual casual sexual
relations before marriage in marriage
which was absent before this movement of
men and women that allows them to have
more freedoms the affluence which
creates a much higher standard of living
and a focus particularly on purchasing
the perfect house and putting the really
one's life savings into this
conjugal home even as the divorce rate
is very high so these things are the
five characteristics there I think
define what I'm calling post-socialist
marriage so it sounds like there is
tremendous change taking place are there
any significant continuities during this
time period um there are I would think
to which are important and one is about
childbearing China continues as in Japan
and Taiwan and in Hong Kong there's very
little Macau bearing outside of marriage
so marriage equates with children one
marries and one becomes a parent there
really isn't too much discussion about
that
moreover children are only born within
marriage so this is a a continuity from
the socialist period into the priests
into where we are now post socialist and
the other is about the intergenerational
investment even in the socialist period
parents even though they couldn't
control the the property in the cities
they couldn't this in the countryside
were very much engaged in helping their
children establish a household if they
could and that has continued so that
parents are deeply involved in the
purchase of these very expensive
condominiums which is the most standard
form so that's those I would say of the
two that merit a children are born
within marriage even though there's a
great deal of sexual experimentation and
latitude about partners inside and
outside of marriage children are really
tied to a married pair which is I'm
thinking about our country and and how
that's very different so I guess my
question is are there higher abortion
rates and higher contraception use then
I would imagine if I don't have the
rates for the u.s. in my head but on the
abortion rate it is so I can't tell you
specifically was it higher or lower than
the United States
the ratio of abortion to birth certainly
went up after 1980 abortion is on
in China and it's not very costly there
are claims and I saw a TV program this
summer which talked about very high
rates of abortion so you know 8 to 1
birth that is totally unbelievable
whether it's 2 to 1 I don't think that's
high I think it's it's much lower but
this would be this would be guesstimates
almost because it's so hard to get that
information on the contraception side
there is contraception is easy to get
it's very low cost and there is they've
done a massive public education push so
that condom use by men is not resisted
in the same extent as it might be in
some other countries and the level of
education in China is so high that I
would I'm not saying all teenage women
or young adults have great knowledge of
how to control their fertility but in
comparison to other countries at the
similar level of development China is
way way ahead so in that respect if you
want to comparison it wouldn't be with
the United States so much but if we
compared it to India Indonesia Nigeria
what we're dealing with or Brazil this
is a population that is very
instrumental in many ways and has enough
education and also availability of
conscious a range of contraception that
people that women in particular have
more control over their fertility than
is true in a comparable level of
development ok let's talk about your
methodology how did you do your research
I use every method I can imagine so I
start with the documents and now in the
last 10 years in China virtually all
statistics that our government released
are also digitally available so that we
have vast storehouses of those types of
documents the legal documents also are
easily available online the hard copy so
I use documents is one way I've done a
lot with Internet
I use blogs I follow blogs in different
ways there's a great deal of media
that's on digitally that's available
digitally for example TV series you hear
afterwards there's a popular TV series
in the past I would have had to be in
China to watch it now I can sit in New
Haven and watch it and then the
connections we have are so good with
China with people going back and forth
you can get an email or a call saying
have you seen this episode and you
actually can just watch it on internet
and there have been some really very
very interesting novellas it was really
what I would call them multi-part
soap-opera light things that are a movie
that would stretch for 56 episodes for
example over over a year or half a year
so I use the internet and I also do a
lot of interviewing for this project
we've done a variety of interviews and
particularly in Shanghai and Guangzhou
and I've also done focus groups because
I think this is a way in which I can get
the natural speech when you're in an
interview you can't you ask people what
they think and then they respond in a
form another formulaic or very measured
way and what I'm interested in very
often is what are the underlying
expectations or underlying anxieties
that people have that is driving their
behavior and what I do in the focus
groups is I set up a problem and then I
open it up and we just steer them and
then we use the transcripts afterwards
to look at what words are spoken by
which people at what point in the
conversation and and that's been useful
okay how does the one policy of the
one-child policy affect the research
that you've done and and is it still in
effect yes it was initially discussed in
79 and and the government chose a group
of nuclear fission scientists to help
development evolve and develop this
policy and it was a letter that went out
not legislation but it has then been
incorporated in other ways so from 1980
onwards this was the rule now in the
rural areas people push back and they
did not comply and there were heavy
penalties people still did not comply
I'm curious what are the penalties well
when it was a socialist system you could
withhold pay you could withhold care
because people there was no market now
there were relatively few penalties
there they can in the city in the
countryside where there's harsh pressure
on local officials they will tear down
people's houses that's right they will
and they put very high financial
penalties on on rural families that era
has passed the policy still is one child
although it's modified in rural areas if
the first child is a boy after four
years your quote allowed to have a group
another child it's more relaxed than
that so in many ways it's functionally
two children in the countryside and one
in the city it was supposed to end after
20 years and the last ten years several
sociologists including my co-author in
the inequality book have been working
with the Chinese government to run
experiments to see what will happen if
you relax will in fact you have a huge
baby boom or not and the results show
that no about 50% of the people will not
go on to have a second or unauthorized
child they're satisfied with a number
that they have and a certain number will
go on mostly those who had a girl and
want a boy but not always there's a
there's a girls are valuable and many
families the ideal is one boy and one
girl and that's really what people would
strive for if there was no limit but we
now are 20 almost 30 years were 30 years
into this policy so that's the
generation of young parents now are
Singleton's themselves and it's not
clear but what Singleton's are they is
there is there a pattern so the
government however continues to be
extremely rigid and say without the
one-child policy we'll have a population
boom umm no experts believe that the
biggest problem in China which is a
result of this policy is one this rapid
aging of the population it it's
extraordinary how quickly they're going
to move to being our very aged society
more than 20% of the population over age
60 but the other piece is this Jen
in balance because the preference for
sons is so strong and these last 20
years it's basically a hundred and
eighteen boys for every hundred girls
and as that group moves into the
marriage age you can see there aren't
enough sure and so this is a very this
is really serious
and unplanned from the perspective of
the government but not unexpected on the
part of the demographers it'll be
interesting to see what the future
brings there finally how do your
conclusions about marriage speak to the
larger trends and social and political
social and political trends in China and
globally as well because of what I've
done for my research I think the number
one is about this property rights issue
that's how I looked at it and what I've
been able to see in this research is is
this gendered piece to the extent that I
almost seems that maleness and
femaleness is more important than class
and money and that's not what you would
necessarily well it's definitely not
what we see in the United States where
class Trump's gender very often in them
in the marriage area so China's is an
interesting case and it highlights this
this issue about gender distinctions in
personal life but how those gender
distinctions do or don't change in the
context of economic changes and legal
changes so I think the property rights
is huge I mean it has implications
beyond for China beyond marriage and
beyond China the second place is this
migration aspect I flagged this vast
migration it has also meant more
cross-border marriages I mean if you
look at the mine at the micro-level
take the case of Taiwan in 2003 31
percent of marriages in Taiwan had a non
Taiwanese spouse most of them were
Chinese from PRC Chinese and what that
means just as in our society when we
look at migration issues cross-border
migration marriage our questions about
citizenship
and questions about you know who is
deserving to be a migrant and what does
it mean to be a citizen so actually from
this marriage issue which to some people
seem so private and micro you're able
actually to look at these much larger
debates about citizenship very
interesting thank you so much for being
here with us today and sharing some of
your work thank you for asking me for
more information about professor Davis
and her research please visit our
website at Yale edu backslash Macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale